CBS News has learned new york police
detectives presented prosecutors with
evidence of new rape allegations against
Harvey Weinstein more than 60 women have
come forward to accused Weinstein of
sexual harassment assault and rape the
new allegations come from paz de la
Huerta who says the disgraced movie
mogul raped her twice
Jericka Duncan spoke with de la Huerta
about her explosive claims to Rico good
morning good morning NYPD sources
investigators rather consider de la
Huerta claims to be credible and they
believe they've gathered enough evidence
for the district attorney to present to
a grand jury for possible charges the
actress is currently in Spain I spoke to
her by phone that's how paz de la Huerta
now describes Harvey Weinstein the man
who gave her one of her first big
Hollywood roles as Mary Agnes in the
1999 movie The Cider House Rules
in October of 2010 de la Huerta says
Weinstein gave her a ride home after a
party and then insisted on having drinks
inside her New York City apartment she
alleges Weinstein pushed her onto her
bed and unzipped his pants are you
saying that he raped you de la Huerta
claims Weinstein raped her a second time
just two months later in December she
says Weinstein showed up unannounced in
the lobby of her building at the time
she says she had been drinking and was
in no state to have consensual sex
[Music]
a senior sex crimes prosecutor has now
been assigned to de la he worked his
case she says she hopes going public
with her claims will help other alleged
victims
[Music]
after the first alleged rate de la
Huerta says she actually confronted
Weinstein at the four seasons in Los
Angeles she claims he was calling her
continuously and she wanted him to leave
her alone now Weinstein did not respond
to our request for comment but he has
repeatedly denied all allegations of
non-consensual sex so yeah his story
hasn't changed and neither have the
women coming forward they're all keep
telling very similar stories you know
methods of operation thank you very much
to Rica very disturbing